oui c'est que les français se sont
détournés des actions depuis 25 ans à
peu près notamment au profit des non
résidents qui sont passés à 45% de la
détention de la détention d des
additions dans le cac 40 est donc et il
est aussi important que nous puissions
défendre là un faux nom dans les
investisse parce que vous inciter à
l'investissement encore faut-il qu'il y
ait un retour sur l'investissement oui
mais je puis dire je veux dire on parle
toujours de du coup de l'allègement de
liesse f on ne parle pas du coût de son
maintien et du fait que nous avons aussi
besoin que des personnes ne quitte pas
le territoire parce que ces personnes
qui sont certes aisée elle paye aussi
par ailleurs de la csg et de l'impôt sur
leurs revenus des taxes foncières de la
tva etc etc
il ya donc beaucoup de rentrer autres
qui sont liées sur sur ces personnes-là
renault temps mais votre devoir
d'explication aujourd'hui pour ce budget
simplement quand on entend le parti
socialiste qui est assez proche quand
même été membre pourquoi est ce que on
est dans ces attaques
geder frontale quand on parle de budget
de riches quand on prend l'exemple savez
d'elliot des voitures de luxe qui vont
est un exemple de dsf
par exemple ce sont des symboles très
fort entre n'y ait pas qu'il ya une
faute peut-être de communication de la
part du gouvernement sur première chose
le parti socialiste les jeux y en a et
est membre très longtemps et j'ai
beaucoup d'attachement pour les
militants qui sont des gens sincères
engagé investi j'ai beaucoup d'amis je
de soutenir qu'elles ont bougé j'ai
gardé beaucoup d'amis je pense que dans
sa stratégie
le parti socialiste a tendance parfois
se complaire dans la facilité de
l'opposition quand il est en gestion il
a du mal à se mettre d'accord entre la
partie je dirais plus gestionnaire et la
partie des frondeurs ont la vue et donc
pour le parti socialiste il ya une
certaine facilité à être dans la lah la
critique l'action permanente d'aller
dans l'opposition permanente
j'entends cette remarque notamment sur
vous avez évoqué les signes extérieurs
de richesse leleu par le le parlement va
travailler le gouvernement à déposer une
copie
moi j'entends travailler sur ces sujets
là avec l'état le modifier rff modifié
et je sais bien je suis bien je ton
petit à modifier faut je crois à
réfléchir à la réalité
ration des signes extérieurs de richesse
dans l'assiette de liesse à vous y est
favorable
je suis favorable à ce que ses traits à
ce que cette réflexion soit lancé et mme
à titre personnel je pense qu'en effet
un signal qui serait de la réintégration
ils résident dans le bon sens mais
encore une fois c'est d'abord le groupe
qui doit en discuter c'est le travail
avec le gouvernement vous savez moi je
suis pour la co élaboration la
co-construction il faut être ni
frondeurs ni godillots il faut
construire